maintenant du côté de l'espace les 15
ans du premier télescope spatial hubble
celui qui a réussi à capter des images
incroyables comme la mort d'une étoile
et la naissance d'un trou noir
une machine à remonter le temps dont
l'avenir est très incertain
bull pourrait s'éteindre dans les années
à venir la nasa n'a pas les moyens de
prolonger sa vie nicolas chateauneuf les
gigantesques piliers de la nébuleuse de
l'aigle la valse mortelle des galaxies
du quintette de stéphane une explosion
de supernova en forme de feu d'artifice
toutes ces images incroyables nous
viennent de beule le plus célèbre des
satellites lancés il ya quinze ans par
la navette discovery
il a tout simplement révolutionné notre
vision de l'univers
pourtant cela avait mal commencé
atteints de myopie à cause d'un défaut
sur son miroir
hubble a dû être réparées trois ans plus
tard en orbite par des astronautes
l'opération fut très délicate mais par
rapport aux meilleurs télescopes
terrestres
ces premières images sont incroyablement
nettes depuis le premier observatoire
spatial a transmis plus de 750 mille
images de l'univers près de nous ce sont
les saisons qui passent sur mars ou
encore la météo cataclysmique de jupiter
mais elle a surtout permis aux
astronomes de pénétrer plus loin que
jamais dans la voûte céleste
ces images du ciel profond et fait le
tour de la terre mais par manque
d'entretien hubble pourrait tomber en
panne d'ici deux ans depuis l'accident
de la navette columbia la nasa juge
l'opération de maintenance trop risqué
mais elle pourrait bientôt changer
d'avis